c'est extraordinaire je pars avec un
pote en fait on arrive à 10h à l'agence
de voyage on voulait partir en bas on va
partir on va partir à l'aventure comme
ça je t'ai dit un pote à moi et il nous
disent ouais si vous voulez il y a un
départ pas cher pour la Thaïlande là à
16h
je regarde
c'est fait
on part direct on part on avait pas
d'hôtel rien on est parti avec un pote à
moi et là et on dit on va je sais pas où
on est dans une région je sais pas où et
là
et là une rigolade dans l'avion parce
que je suis avec mon pote et là il y a
un mec qui nous parle nous on fait ça et
tout vous allez où bah nous on part on
va pocketa on a normalement vous êtes
français vous êtes que tous les deux
ouais ouais tranquille vous connaissez
un peu là-bas non quoi personne on y va
comme ça on y va pour rien c'est-à-dire
quand même il y a deux Français qui sont
fait égorger la semaine dernière
ah ouais sympa
on y va comme ça hein pour rigoler hein
d'accord c'est très bien on arrive
là-bas il y a un gars qui nous prend en
charge en thaïlandais et il disait que
ça dans la voiture il était comme ça et
c'est ils arrêtent pas dire match lady
in pocket Town match Lady ouais mais en
fait ouais il y a quoi à pokéda match
ladies bon donc on est allé là-bas et
première chose qu'on fait
décalage horaire on arrive le soir on a
même pas d'hôtel on arrive je vous le
dis la vérité on va direct en boîte ça
veut dire les mecs ils ont une odeur
direct on va direct en bois là on arrive
dans une boîte et bon bien sûr on
connaît personne
donc voilà et à un moment je vois mon
pote partir avec une meuf sur un scooter
je me retrouve là-bas tout seul dans la
boîte en train de céder comme un ouf
[Musique]
ah tu connaissais personne
l'histoire est vrai je me retrouve à 3h
du matin sur un bon il y avait des bons
en bois avec des mecs qui mangeaient des
souples des trucs en sortie de la boîte
je suis comme as et là je vois défiler
ma vie je dis mais qu'est-ce que je fais
là
je suis tout seul en Thaïlande il est 3h
du matin je suis sur un bon et je dis et
là je vous revois mon pote passé avec la
meuf qu'est-ce que tu fais toi rien
t'inquiète pas amuse-toi mon cœur c'est
bon donc voilà et à combien de temps
mais Barka écoute-moi le lendemain alors
on a dormi dans un truc pourri on a
trouvé et le lendemain je suis reparti
bien sûr je suis reparti à Paris un jour
stop stop
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]